Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunis step out  for a day date I just also know the  couple was spotted out and about in LA  Ashton kept it cash and a baseball tee  and a hat while Mila had that pregnancy  glow in a black and white striped maxi  dress and simple sandals  the stars are of course expecting their  second child together last month  Mila opened up to et about parenting  they're almost two year old daughter Y  every night that we put Wyatt down we  high-five each other more like we did it  every single day we kept her alive we're  like she's a lot and we're still in love  like it's a you high five would you  still like each other and used to like  your kid at the end of the night